earlier you mentioned something about a
oneness
it with regard to memory what are you
referring to there
well yesterday i met with my uh monthly
coaching group where we talk about
memory stuff and i gave them an exercise
which is
or a game we played which is i said a
sentence which was a white cat ate a
frog
and then the next student said a
sentence and then the next student said
a sentence and we all have to repeat the
sentence that the previous person said
that's great
and i'm introducing intuit numbers i'm
introducing intuit adjectives i'm
introducing into it
and they are naturally also and when we
got to the end like everybody fails
quite quickly because it's quite hard
right
but um you know and somebody had
mentioned uh
peyton manning who i guess is a football
player i'd never heard of this person
before
but uh i used preston manning who i
think was the leader of the reform party
at some point in canadian political
history as my image for that
now when i what i described to them
after is one of the reasons why i
played the game better than they did is
because i don't see the information
different than they do they they think
oh my goodness now i have to account for
a verb
what image am i going to use for a verb
oh peyton manning is number one is what
one person one student said
now i have to think number one which is
somehow different than the name
uh peyton manning right and i just
i don't see it that way because i've
created this
set of tools that allows me to just make
it information as such
and there's a experience of oneness with
the information
because you're that fast in terms of
elaborative encoding it's called
so when you look at the kids who i mean
it's not even just kids but
just call them kids because they're
getting younger and younger in the
memory competitions
um they're memorizing decks of cards in
like 17 seconds 12 seconds
52 individual cards in order
with 100 accuracy there's a oneness
that's going on between
multiple layers of information order
suit
number perhaps they're even referring to
color in how they process
suits and there's
this is happening because the mind has
been trained to disregard distortion
and just connect in the moment
but multi-layer multi-layers of
information all the same
the mind has been trained or their mind
because they were
memory champions or working toward being
that their mind has been trained or the
my
all of our minds are trained like that
well i don't know if we want to get into
non-duality and uh the potential that
it's just one mind doing it
but let's just say for practice for
practical purposes somebody sat there
and
like an individual unit of consciousness
sat there
and trained the meat factory that is you
know
somehow producing that that and so the
person who didn't train that
isn't going to do it you know my best
time with cards is two minutes and 30
seconds
and i got bored and i'm just like not
going to get faster than that
because you know there's no practical
benefit to my life
to be able to memorize faster than two
minutes and 30 seconds but i can tell
you
in that moment you're one with all the
things
it's it's like being in task positive
network or what uh mihai chick sent me
how you calls uh
flow it's just flow but to get there
you have to annihilate the idea that
information is different
it's it's just it's just information and
you have the tools and you just